let's uh let's segue over to schools
because i did say i was going to talk
about this we definitely should because
this story is
hilarious yeah this is interesting i
have to bring this story up because
they drag ben shapiro and jordan
peterson is all right of course the
stupidest thing ever
and it is woke teachers look at this
the kids are alt-right when your star
pupil gets red pilled
from mel magazine teachers know the
warning signs
when students are radicalized by online
hate movements they just don't know how
to stop it or if it's a power struggle
they can
ever win how creepy is it
that these people literally view the
enlightenment
as a hate movement because they
specifically reference
jordan peterson joe rogan oh man i gotta
read you this paragraph they say
often it's hard for teachers to tell
whether a student is being truly
red-pilled in the sense that they're
being radicalized online
or whether they're parodying views that
they've grown up with in their
conservative households
of course tessa a 29 year old in the
midwest who teaches 14 to 18 year olds
at a private school for students
with learning impairments says that
while many of her students simply take
on the talking points and politics of
their conservative parents
this can make them especially ripe
targets for full-blown radicalization
and infatuation with far-right figures
quote a few started listening to joe
rogan's podcast
which led them to reading jordan
peterson's books
she said i think that joe rogan's
ideology is the biggest threat to
critical thinking in the last decade
i i got it yeah yeah for that one
seriously
i gotta say stop because if you think
joe rogan
is far right that should tell you
exactly how far
left you are because this something is
wrong with you and to
then to say that he's the biggest threat
to critical thinking
nah i love when when the first time i
went on rogan he goes what do you think
about universal basic income
oh yeah and i was like not a big fan for
these readings like yeah yeah but and a
bunch of people
like pushed me and i'm like joe's almost
a socialist
yeah like he's he's in no way right wing
culturally
i think he's like centrist and then
economically he leans left
i think he has common sense and right
now that makes him a little bit
right-wing it's because they're in a
death cult and anyone outside of the
cult
is literally hitler that's a better
summary when it gets better they say oh
boy there are some obvious
warning signs that a student is being
red-pilled though
like when they have a sudden and
noticeable rightward shift in their
views
when they specifically mention figures
like ben shapiro and peterson
who olivia says her student loved and
when they use language that makes the
online influence obvious like chad
and [ __ ] ah brilliant the word chad and
cuck
yes evidence that your child has been
red pilled
there's always been boys who ask don't
girls just lie about
uh assault though and we do want to take
those questions seriously
ferderber verteber says but increasingly
they're using language that sounds
straight from reddit
reddit is super far left do they know
do any of these teachers know what
they're talking about
because it doesn't sound like they do if
they think if they think ben shapiro is
all right
they don't know the first thing about
the alt-right right or the first thing
about ben shapiro
well i mean as evidenced by everything
they say
they clearly don't know anything and and
help us they're teaching our children
yeah well not my kids i don't have any
kids this should be a huge thank you
home school
homeschool your kids there's a meme
going around it's funny and it was like
if the left is calling this guy a nazi
and this woman a white supremacist then
you know you're you know
they're trying to brainwash you and it
was ben shapiro and candace owens yes
a jewish guy who was the biggest target
of
you know white supremacists and
anti-semites according to the adl
and a black woman literal orthodox jew
tiny hat guy
yeah yes not all right guys not possible
oh man when teachers notice the warning
signs of radicalization
difficult questions arise where is the
line between
shutting down these arguments and
allowing kids to explore new ideas
and when is the right moment to
intervene
okay look if someone's listening to
jordan peterson
i'm going to be like cool because he
said he's a
well-balanced guy and you know he's been
out of the scene for for a little bit
if someone's listening to joe rogan i
would say good yes
because joe is a regular dude
but you can see how radicalized they are
that's the crazy thing
what this article really says is are
your kids being pulled from the cult
we saw that thread it was viral thread
where a guy was complaining
that parents now with virtual classrooms
would start to learn about what they
were teaching their kids
that's terrifying and they're
indoctrinating these kids with these
ridiculously insane curriculums on
racial justice and this cult dogma and
they don't want parents to find out
parents should know exactly what the
curriculum is parents should be given
the syllabus with all
of like here's the plan for the month
here's the plan for the quarter parents
should be
more involved than the teachers are and
i believe that 100
and not just because i was homeschooled
for most of my life
i honestly think and i don't know if you
guys noticed while he was reading this
but
if you saw the ages of the teachers i
saw 34
i saw 29 and i saw 28.
millennials yes it's always our fault
what happened
to millennials dude i mean gen z is bit
split
i guess i guess everybody's a bit split
how weird is this but y'all you know
what man
i'll tell you in 10 years i you i'm it's
going to be in 10 years from now i'm
going to be telling stories about how i
used to be a liberal and a democrat and
all that stuff
and then these young people are going to
view it as one day
i changed my opinions and became a
republican when in reality is
my opinion stayed where they were the
republican party just a lot like
became the bigger tent yeah the bigger
the you know for for more people
focused on individual liberty rights
civil you know social justice and all
these
like real social justice and the left
went insane i would compare it more
to like being on a hill the blob of the
republican party rolled downhill a
little bit
and it took you in and the left blob
rolled way off down into the distance
i'm confused by what your analogy is
supposed to my analogy makes perfect
sense
i'm sorry you don't understand it so the
whole like it's like blanketing yeah
it's like a teeter-totter almost
i don't think uh the republican party
has
shifted no no yeah yeah so like i often
talk about the wheel
how you've got far left and far right
and the wheel can turn wonder i don't
think the republican party did i think
the republican party became a bigger
tent no i've seen the right i've seen
the right wing
shift i've seen a lot more maybe
maybe you're right but i i've seen it
shift at least on topics like gay
marriage
because there was a point i remember a
point in my life where it went from
being totally unacceptable to being
is the way it is now but but that's not
i don't think that negates what i'm
saying
when you make a bigger tent and you
bring in a bunch of liberals
then what is the center of your party
shifts a little bit to the left
it doesn't get rid of the people already
on the right of your party you see what
i'm saying
yeah yeah there's still a lot of people
who don't believe in
you know gay marriage that's true and
lgbtq rights
maybe i'm just talking about my own
family and my microbes they've shifted
they changed
i i think it's fair though i you know
i've mentioned in the past that donald
trump is a republican
and he's the first president in u.s
history to be pro-gay marriage
before going into office yeah and i
think you know
uh i'm not entirely sure about this i
know barack obama was was opposed to gay
marriage the first in his first campaign
before he was for it yeah but i think he
was opposed to in a second run wasn't he
first i think the first one the second
one the first part of his second
uh oh yeah so he ran twice opposed to
gay marriage
i think so that's i mean i'm not going
to blame obama for that because
well society changes of course now
that's why i think it's silly when um
you know uh what was it is that his name
he put out that ad where he said
you know joe biden multiple times came
out against gay marriage
and i can respect that i get his point
because donald trump entered and he
doesn't have that on you know in his
history
but come on you know look joe biden's
changed yeah
times have changed he's gotten with the
program he's changed his opinion i'm
more concerned about what he's doing now
and his character now i can respect you
know grinnell's opinion for sure he
knows better than i do because he is a
gay man
but i look at what joe biden and kamala
harris represent now
i'm concerned about the now not the not
the yesterday exactly however
i look at joe biden's wishy-washiness
his flip
is waffling and what the obama
administration did and that does matter
because they do have a history and
that's important perhaps you could say
that donald trump doesn't you know
because he doesn't have that history
it's harder to criticize him it's his
first time running for office and he
became president
right yeah i mean that was a really
funny thing that's amazing brought it up
i ran for president one time
i ran for public office one time and
became president of the united states is
funny
so he has that advantage but i look at
the the biden administration and the
things they did
and that's why i'm like none of that
none of that
yeah i'm not interested in that theo
biden obama administration the obide
obama let's
let me read out the last paragraph
because i mentioned the proud voice i
think it's funny
they say it can also be devastating for
teachers to realize that
despite their best efforts some of their
students might end up holding hateful
beliefs long term
and many of them take it personally
quote my biggest worry is that they'll
be stuck in that in their thinking
forever and that they'll join the proud
boys or something tessa says
i feel like i should be able to do a
better job at teaching critical thinking
skills
and they should have enough trust in me
to believe that i'm telling the truth
honestly she adds it makes me feel like
i failed at my job
well you failed at your job for a lot of
reasons i'll tell you what
if i had to choose if there was a little
kid in front of me
and they were like you could say one
thing just one word
or you have two choices he either grows
it become a proud boy or
grows up to become antifa and you can
only you have to choose
i'd rather that kid be proud boy 100
because the worst thing about the proud
boys is that they may be
rambunctious and aggressive but they
don't start
fights for the most part it's like
another i mentioned this you know
several times now it's inverse
uh proportions antifa almost exclusively
starts the fights
proud boys tend to finish them when the
fights start but proud boys have started
some fights
for the most part if if you leave them
to their business they walk around
waving american flags and then go get
drunk at a bar that's totally fine i
don't care
don't you know antifa instigates and
gets violent and goes and targets people
and that
is not acceptable the entire basis of
the proud boys is kind of unserious
it's a bunch of hazing it's a bunch of
gross dirty immature jokes it wasn't
meant to be anything crazy
how crazy how how weird is it now that
people have like tattoos
and they it's they take it seriously
that's funny to me see
to me it's like the embodiment almost of
a sense of humor
whereas with antifa it's just dark it's
depressing
like i don't i don't understand why
anyone would want to be part of that
because it's not exciting it's not
interesting it's not fun it's not like
enjoyable
well these these teachers are worried
that these children may listen to jordan
peterson and then become proud boys
that's pretty sorry yeah i sympathize
they may learn how to clean their rooms
is it the worst the worst thing you have
to worry about is they'll start talking
about lobsters and cleaning their room
and carrying heavy things i am not
worried about people
actually i've said it before i think
jordan peterson's um
self-help ideology and things like that
were an antidote
to chaos i mean that's quite literally
the point of his book what he set out to
do
i i look at it like this i i have a
video on my main channel where i talk
about this
i think our generation and the younger
generations have no purpose
and that's creating two kind of like
pockets
the people who are attracted attracted
to jordan peterson's message
are looking for purpose and he says be
responsible
find the heaviest thing you can carry
and carry it you have to do it
and so people learn to become
responsible for themselves
the other faction who hate him found a
fake
way to fill that that void in their in
their soul purpose and meaning and its
intersectionality
so he he's he's actually giving people
meaning and purpose
and it's harming their cult naturally
they hate him
that makes sense so i think when you
tell somebody to treat yourself like
someone you are responsible for that's
i think that if someone taught isn't
that deep because
to me that's really deep because if you
have someone that you really care about
you're not going to let themself you're
not going to let them put themselves
down
you're not going to let them be loose or
sloppy or crazy or silly or
overly emotional you're going to help
them be disciplined
you're going to help them see themselves
in the correct light you're going to
guide them you're going to really care
about what happens
but it's you right that's interesting
that's a good way to put it
i love that and i think i think antifa
would be so much better off if you
floated them that idea and you didn't
tell them who it was from
i wonder how many of them would actually
think about that i think they're unwell
they they don't take responsibility for
themselves they want they want
things to be provided for them and that
is just it's unacceptable in my opinion
yeah
i don't want to take it too far i don't
want to think it's too late
i would like to think that they're a
leftist who thinks that some memes are
funny and i'd like to think there's some
antifa members who would consider
treating themselves like there are
responsibilities it's just like i said
those inverse proportions right
so on the left you do have some honest
personalities
and uh many of them many of them i'm not
going to pretend like it's it's you know
only
screeching banshees or whatever no
there's there's a bunch of
good people on the left uh but i think
there's too many bad ones yeah there are
many bad ones on the right but there are
many good ones to me it seems easier to
be
a person of character on the left and
get more respect for it
at least from the right or from people
generally because
they're like four-leaf clovers they're
not everywhere they're kind of special
it's a little bit like finding a unicorn
in the wild it's like i need to respect
this person
jimmy doreman yeah like a car out of
those left-wing people i'm like i have
huge respect for you
jimmy is awesome jimmy dore is awesome
and i disagree with him on a lot of
things right i don't care if we disagree
on stuff but but he's
he's he's honest yeah i think he gets
some things wrong
and same thing with kyle kalinski and
david pakman but i think they're
for the most part um i think these are
these are these are good dudes
not perfect but i think jimmy dore is is
great he recently went on tucker carlson
and he said the democratic party is the
pro war party and they're laughing about
it i'm like this is awesome
yeah it's jimmy and tucker laughing and
and tucker was like i i appreciate you
doing this considering the flack you're
gonna get and and
jimmy was like it was worth it yeah
absolutely that's great it's great
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode